hi there today I want to talk about the
role of forgetting in language learning
it's going to be a little bit of a
confused presentation because I haven't
all these thoughts haven't really
settled in my mind
it starts with a video that I watched
video presented by Robert Bjork of UCLA
and it's entitled the theory of disuse
and the role of forgetting and I'm gonna
leave a link in the description
basically he talks about he is an expert
has spent his life studying memory and
in fact if you go to this video you'll
find other videos in YouTube which are
all well worth watching and much of what
he presents is counterintuitive
it's not what you would expect starting
with this this this whole issue of how
we learn and and the main point is that
the putting it very simply the more we
forget the more we learn and so if we
learn something and then leave it in
other words disuse we don't worry about
it for a while we don't cram it for the
exam we learned it we forget it and then
we relearn it later on in other words we
retrieve it later on then that is where
learning takes place and that if we have
a number of sort of a narrow range of
bits of information that we can easily
retrieve we are not in fact increasing
our memory storage
we are not increasing our learning and
so that's to me is very very important
if I relate that to my own approach to
language learning I tend not to stay
with beginner texts graded readers
you know 5% unknown words I as soon as I
with the language that's very closely
related to what I know like Ukrainian I
just go straight into the difficult
material I'm sure I can do that for
Dutch I can do it for Polish now based
on my checking and Ukrainian I can then
go back later and this gets back to this
issue have been leaving I can go back
later and look up some points of grammar
because by that time I'll have had some
exposure to the language but I'll forget
again and I'll put it away somewhere and
when I can retrieve it then that will
all expand my learning so that if the
ultimate goal is to achieve some degree
of fluency then we are better off to
learn forget learn and forget look up a
word forget it look up word forget it
but to deal with a lot of unknown words
rather than limiting ourselves to easy
material this also relates to some of
the other things that dr. Bjork mentions
in some of his other videos one is the
importance of context so if I'm working
let's say of link and I save a blue word
maybe yellow I forget what it means I
see it in a different context two three
five ten days later so I'm seeing these
words in different contexts another
thing points out is that we learn better
if we learn in different contexts so
that if we are studying for a history
exam and we study in the you know in the
open under a tree and then we study in a
classroom and in library these different
contexts research shows helps us to
learn context determines how we process
information how we code information and
so yeah I could be looking at on my I
added on my iPad in bed I could be
working on my computer I could be doing
other stuff but even in terms of the the
context they've spoken like the audio or
the written context that I'm learning
from the more I'm varying the context
and covering and meeting the same words
the easier is going to be to retain so
to
you know it's better to learn and forget
therefore don't try to ace a narrow bit
of content where you are able to
retrieve it all or to study a list of
words until you can retrieve it all what
you're doing is actually reducing the
amount of learning if I understand what
dr. Bjork says whereas if you simply
learn forget leave it out somewhere it's
now in storage next time you need it
because you're reading it if you don't
link you'll see it in yellow you click
on it again you see it run run up
against it somewhere else maybe you do
better flashcard it you see it there so
you're coming up against it in different
context but not necessarily with the
idea of retaining it in other words we
get away from the idea of tests he does
say Robert York the testing is good in
that it forces you to try and retrieve
it but if we are reading said link where
you have the yellow words every time you
see a word you don't remember what it
means you're testing yourself so there's
a built-in testing mechanism when you
are reading these texts which have all
these words that you have looked up
before and have already forgotten
forgotten so that is in a sense and yeah
testing forcing and retrieve things that
you've forgotten and you may not next
time you come across it you may not
automatically retrieve it again but
eventually you will so I would encourage
people to go after difficult content one
other thing that he says which is
important in one of his videos he refers
to a book called the third source and
that which basically says that
traditionally the sources of Education
were the family context and the
classroom and now we have so many more
opportunities using technology using the
internet that this will become the sort
of third sort of Education and what that
means is that increasingly learning will
not be supervised learning will be
independent and therefore it's very
important that as learners we come up
with a strategy that works and as again
dr. Bjork
though there are many things that about
what works in terms of learning that are
counterintuitive so it's very easy if
we're in an unsupervised environment to
do things that are not that effective
what he does say that is a good thing is
that in this third source of learning
away from the classroom in fact there is
more freedom to experiment whereas many
of these non-intuitive ways of learning
you know forgetting as a means of
learning these are harder to introduce
in a school system where you have a
curriculum where you have testing where
you have all kinds of standards
expectations by school boards parents
and so forth whereas when we get to this
truly unsupervised area learning we can
experiment but therefore it's important
to not get fooled by the sense that
we're learning something when in fact
we're not learning very effective
effectively and that's always my feeling
and getting back to this interleaving
blocked learning versus you know
staggered learning that I discovered
when learning German that if I continue
to try to learn the the declension
tables after a while you know yeah I'm
looking at them so I'm retrieving it
more easily and more easily because it's
right there I'm only focused on this but
within a few days it's gone
whereas if that same bit of information
is saved in different contexts saying
link people are gonna knock me for
mentioning link but that's how I learn
languages so that's what I'm gonna talk
about that seeing it then in these
different contexts and forgetting it and
retrieving it is probably in the long
run more effective than just cramming
something you know where your event to
get to the point where you are
retrieving it easily but you're not
increasing your learning so I hope
that's not too confusing and I suggest
you go and have a look at dr. Robert
Bjork's videos thank you for listening
bye